rencontrer et informer les acteurs du
monde associatif
tels sont les objectifs de cette journée
réseau associatif sur un même site les
organismes accompagnateurs de la vie
associative ont pu échanger avec les
dirigeants les bénévoles et les
créateurs de ces structures
le département est un acteur
incontournable de l'action sociale donc
là c'est de manière tout à fait naturel
que la ville de saint-andré s'est tourné
vers nous pour participer à cette
journée puisque nous sommes bien
évidemment chef de file en matière
d'action sociale
alors aujourd'hui nous avons représenté
la famille enfance l'autonomie avec le
volet personnes âgées personnes
handicapées l'habitat la culture et le
sport et l'insertion bien évidemment les
associations sont un relais sur les
territoires dont qu'ils interviennent de
manière complémentaire au niveau des
services territorialisée dons qui sont
vraiment des acteurs de premier plan de
proximité avec la population
à 32 ans gaël charlottine souhaitent
s'investir dans le monde socio éducatif
auprès des jeunes
le modèle associatif lui permettrait de
concrétiser ses projets je suis venu
surtout pouvoir découvrir pour voir un
petit peu les différents partenaires qui
existe
dans le domaine de l'associatif qu elles
n ont peu à voir avec qui on peut être
suivi donc c'est vrai c'est très très
intéressant cette journée ça nous permet
vraiment de savoir à quelle porte
frapper pour arrêter c'est pas toujours
facile d'ouvrir une association mais là
on a vraiment toutes les on va dire les
caractéristiques les deux monnaies sont
là département comme ça mais je frappe à
toutes les portes en fait avant donc
voilà allez conseil bon on va dire c'est
plutôt à dire dans le côté social
donc c'est vraiment de mettre en place
des actions dans ce domaine
donc on peut éventuellement avoir des
aides si on met en place des actions
avec les familles en matière organisé
par la commune de saint-andré cette
action vise à favoriser le développement
des associations sur le territoire le
département de la réunion a notamment
détaché sur le site
le service des sports et la direction de
l'enfance et de la famille conseil
départemental afin de réaliser sport
nous accompagnons les clubs qui ont
alors à leur charge de nous de nous de
me ramener l'élite de demain ça veut
dire les sportifs de demain des sportifs
de haut niveau
donc on a les aides au club ça veut dire
des subventions
on a eu
subvention de fonctionnement subventions
manifestation nous avons aussi un
travail d'accompagnement envers l'élite
qui est actuellement à la réunion et
hors de la réunion
son rôle est primordial et heureusement
pour nous c'est une efficacité au niveau
de la direction de l'enfance et de la
famille
ce qu'est la collectivité peut
intervenir sur l'aide sur trois trois
volets le volet de l'aide à la
parentalité le volet de l'aide
alimentaire et le volet de la lutte
contre les violences intrafamiliales
sont les trois domaines sur lesquels
certains partenaires associatifs
associatif par dont peuvent bénéficier
de subventions particulièrement
aujourd'hui c'est le champ de la
parentalité qui intéresse les personnes
qui viennent et qui mène souvent des
actions des actions de proximité en
faveur de familles en difficulté ou
alors alors en difficulté avec avec
leurs enfants dans la prise en charge
quotidienne de leurs enfants ou des
associations qui veulent mettre en place
des actions ponctuelles du type des
sorties familiales qui permettent de
travailler de maintenir le lien parent
enfant